our people we had harry potter we had
Twilight now we have Hunger Games the
next big book thing is it anything like
those films is it better is it worse
stay tuned Hunger Games now this is a
film that is interesting for me because
I went in this film knowing virtually
nothing except for the plot I did not
read the books so I went into this film
completely oblivious to whatever I was
going to see whatever was on screen was
going to be a surprise to me I just knew
that Jennifer Lawrence was a great
actress and then essentially the plot is
that it's a strange world it's a whole
bunch of colonies of people who are very
poor and are trying to survive and
there's this whole group of very rich
people who put on this gladiator like
show every year in which they force
children they pick randomly by name out
of a jar to fight and kill themselves to
the death and there's one victor in this
battle and they do it every year it's
called The Hunger Games it's kind of
like the Running Man with Arnold
Schwarzenegger except a lot more serious
and a lot more dark and it involves
children there's a lot of hype behind
The Hunger Games tons of high blood
people have been building this and
talking about it for a long time and I
try to stay away from hype I don't like
to get too involved with that and so for
that reason I was very excited to be
able to walk into this film not knowing
hardly anything and I can report to you
that I enjoyed the film very much for me
Jennifer Lawrence is probably the
strongest part of this movie her
performance is great she is such a
skilled actress her performance was real
you really felt for her character she
was never over-the-top she was strong
she was a strong female character which
I always like to see she was supportive
of her family but also really strong
throughout the entire battle also the
film is very tense at times and there's
something really dark about this movie
and a lot of it is because a lot of the
action and violence revolves around
children the violence is never glorified
it's never looked at is a good thing or
a fun thing it's something that's very
looked down upon and you really start to
hate the people who are running this
show I mean you just want to see that
show just fail and sometimes it was
honestly a little hard for me to believe
that people could honestly find so much
enjoyment in watching children fight to
the death I just feel like that was a
little far-fetched I just can't imagine
anyone just watching that and thinking
yes this is awesome stuff but then also
lends to the movie because then you
really want her to fight against the
system you want her to succeed you want
to see her succeed in what she's trying
to do and so it lends to the movie as
well because you get even more invested
in her character the director of this
film Gary Ross he uses a lot of shaky
cam
and in this film I think it lent a lot
to it I think it worked very well
because it didn't feel clean or polished
and because of that shakey cam usage I
think it lent to the more like the
feeling like you get it sometimes
because some of the stuff you've seen
this movie really disturbed me and
bothered me and I even now I think back
and I'm like ah I don't know if I want
to see that part again
the violence level is pg-13 for sure
it's just that it's involved with kids
and so you feel this sort of tenseness
that you don't normally feel at the
movie and it really added to the weight
of the impact of some of the things that
were happening I didn't have a few
problems with this movie though for one
I just do not buy Josh Hutton
that his name yeah he seems like a cool
guy but he just doesn't fit into this
movie for me Jennifer Lawrence was
delivering such a great performance that
he felt kind of teeny bopper ish in this
movie I think he did fine for his role I
just feel like they should have picked a
different actor and although the film
was very nail-biting I feel like it
could have been even more nail-biting I
wanted a little bit more suspense I just
wanted that it wasn't as good as I think
it could have been I think it was a very
well-done film very well acted very well
directed but I feel like it could have
been a little bit better also there's a
problem that sometimes comes when you
have a first film or a second film that
was part of a trilogy
it feels anticlimactic and that's
understandable there are two more films
coming right now though I feel like oh I
wanted just a little bit more
I can understand though cuz in the
future I'll take all three of these
films I'll watch them back-to-back and
it'll feel right more than likely
besides the fact though because this is
a very well acted tense film with
extremely good set pieces and some
really intense moments that really grab
you and can actually get under your skin
a little bit people compared a lots of
things like twilight simply because it's
adapted from a book and a lot of young
adults like it it's nothing like that at
all it's far more serious it's
definitely a better film I'm going to
give the hunger games of B+ I enjoyed it
very much I think if you are a fan of
the books that you'll probably enjoy too
it's just that I can't really give you
that idea of you know book to movie
adaptation since I haven't read the
books also my local news channel was at
the theater and I got interviewed and I
was on the news I put a link to that
story you can actually watch the video
if you want to see me on the news and
what I would love for you guys to do if
you could is just comment on that saying
hey you know Chris stuckman sent me here
or something just to let him know that
you guys are
appreciate it if you do that for me I'd
really appreciate it until next time
guys if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]